Je pense que j'ai commencé l'idée d'
écrire The Book Thief juste à partir d'histoires que
ma mère et mon père m'avaient racontées sur le fait de
grandir en Allemagne pendant la guerre
en avril 1933, il y avait des
cambriolages massifs où ils détruisaient des
livres en s'assurant de ce que les gens
lisaient et pensaient  était allemand à
cause de la puissance de
tout ce qui aidait à la liberté d'expression à l'étranger et la
pensée avait été détruite viens
Lisa rencontrer Ian tes parents
Lisa vient vivre avec un esprit maléfique et
c'est une sorte de sentiment que tu vois à travers
ses yeux tu ne peux même pas lire  pourtant continuez à
lire un mot les fourmis
réalisant qu'elle est analphabète mais qu'elle a une
étincelle et de l'énergie pour vouloir apprendre l'
encourage à apprendre à lire et à
écrire et pas une si bonne raison moi-même
vous savez que nous devrons nous entraider
elle est plongée dans  ce monde d'histoires et de
mots et elle vole un livre mais toujours en train de
couver du feu que vous avez allumé
faisons de cela notre secret
Hritik dans le sous-
sol à Arlen il y avait des individus qui sont
allés  hors de leur chemin pour aider les gens dans le
besoin wizzy papa
son nom max et chacune de ces personnes
risquent leur vie et mettent la
vie des autres en premier livre de gare
écoutez totalement si le mien s'il vous plaît prêtez max
ayez une grande parenté à cause des livres
dites-moi où allez-vous  obtenez ces mots
c'est un secret
et à qui dirais-je que je t'ai acheté
quelque chose
tu es plein de merveilles ces histoires sont
vraiment au cœur de The Book Thief
elles nous montrent le pouvoir des mots
et ce que nous pouvons être vos livres de scellement
pourquoi  un couteau vole vous devez parfois le
faire reculer les
mots sont un laser de vie si vos yeux pouvaient
parler que diraient-ils qu'il a un si
bon message à travers toutes les
choses sombres il y a toujours du bon qui en
ressort - lettre d'amour ^ histoire comment  ça
sauve des vies
humaines les naissances peuvent venir absolument
tout ce que tu m'as gardé en vie facile
n'oublie jamais ce bon
voleur de livres